well here's the book it's titled the
devil we know dealing with the new
Iranian superpower New York Times best
seller the author is Robert Baer who
joins us this morning live from Berkeley
California and mr. Baer is a former CIA
operative and and and why'd you pick
this title first off mr. Baer the devil
we know what he's saying here the
implication is that we actually know it
ran very well we've had a strained
relationship to put it nicely over the
years it but what I'm trying to say it's
a it's a predictable country it's a
country that's fall falling a a
revolutionary arc if you like became was
very violent 79 continued through the
80s and then became a much more mature
power you know it's sort of a rands
Thermidor so by 1996 it was it was no
longer conducting terrorism against the
United States so over the last 13 years
now it's we've had fairly even relations
with Iran you use the word superpower as
well in that cover dealing with the new
Iranian superpower but that word in
perspective here you know it's a word
you know it's it's like I'll be frank
with you had the publisher picked it I I
would prefer hegemon in the Persian Gulf
simply by the fact that it can cut off
oil supplies it can I ran can mine the
Gulf Iran can rocket Saudi Arabia's oil
facilities Iran can take off 40% of
world's traded oil within minutes and in
that sense it could take control of the
Persian Gulf ninety percent of the
Persian Gulf is Shia Twelver Shia which
in one former and other answers to Iran
so Iran is the only you know large power
in the Gulf if we were to withdraw one
day Iran would fill a vacuum taking it a
step deeper you write in the prologue
page for Robert Baer scratch away the
veneer of Islam and what you find in an
Iranian is old-fashioned nationalism a
deep abiding defiance of colonialism
keep scratching and what you find at the
bottom of Iran's soul is a new
found taste for Empire speak more to to
what this country is looking to achieve
I think in terms of hegemony it wants to
control it wants to make sure that the
the countries on its border answered to
Tehran in one way or another not not by
occupation but what they want to do is
have gana stand Iraq's Central Asia in
the Arab countries in one way or another
deferring to Tehran on unimportant
national security issues and and as they
would I mean is just as we would like to
have Ottawa defer to us or Mexico defer
to us in the same way I ran would like
the same I mean it's not it's occupation
is a bad word or Empire is a bad word
because it doesn't really apply they
just wanted predominance of influence in
that region phone numbers on the bottom
of the screen for Robert Baer who's out
in Berkeley California we're talking
about Iran and there are lines for
Republicans Democrats and independents
we'll start taking your calls in just a
moment Robert Baer remind us of a your
career with CIA to the extent you can
how many years where were you and then
spin it off into what you actually saw
in Iran because you had spent
considerable time there I spent 21 years
in the CIA
almost all of it in the Middle East the
CIA put me through Arabic two years of
it I served in Levant I served in
Lebanon during the worst years Morocco
Syria Lebanon
or else I've been to Iran on visits
before the Revolution and most recently
as Morocco and I was in France for a
while where I covered the Middle East so
it's mine my entire career has been in
the Middle East I resigned from the CIA
in December 1997 I was involved in an
aborted coup in Iraq in March 1995 and I
just left to do other things mainly to
write and when you look at the Iranians
themselves before we get to calls here's
a passage from the book it's a country
of nuances you write Americans see
Iran's president and mullahs as relics
from a dark age when in reality they're
a driving force behind Iran's
modernization speak more to that the
leadership especially the religious
leadership and the people well you look
at the religious leadership today after
I wrote the book and they are truly the
opposition to how meny that the supreme
leader I mean they are the ones comb now
is the center of opposition you look at
you see look at rocks on Johnny whose
has come out for democracy in their
terms several other mullahs have
condemned the violence in in Tehran and
so you see it's much more nuanced
society we tend to look at Ayatollah
Khomeini --an and that's where our
images of Iran rest is in this firebrand
spreading revolution creating a
religious state but Iran has matured
it's a change country and what I try to
do in the book is is is head that's the
backdrop for the book but on the other
hand the real the real story in my book
is the Islamic Revolutionary Guard Corps
I served on the periphery of Iran but
not in Tehran so what I know is Iran's
edge of expansion through the Middle
East and who these people are in the
Islamic Revolutionary Guard Corps
because they're very important they are
taking key positions right now the new
Minister of Defense nominated is from
the Revolutionary Guard Corps he has a
long violent history on the other hand
he is a man who is abandoned violence as
far as we can see in terms of foreign
expansion
anyhow that's you know it there is
theory that you can see empires better
from the periphery I mean I'm not a
position to argue that but the fact is I
was on Iran's periphery and that's the
aperture which I look through first call
for Robert Baer out in California st.
Clair Shores Michigan Robert you're on
the Republican line hi Robert
yeah good morning morning hi mr. Baer
how are you Hank morning hi good morning
uh my voice by the way my brother-in-law
is a is currently working for your
former employer I you know I'm very
curious about Iran I find them rather
fascinating as I do most in Middle East
I picked up a textbook basically it was
a series and read the history of Iran as
best I could it's very complicated and I
noticed that in their history I was
looking for you know the Bush
administration was constantly saying
that they were a threat to virtually
everybody and I couldn't understand I
did it didn't seem right to me and so I
read this book and there were moments in
history now that's history and today's
today I understand that but their
history of the people they're very
cultured and very intelligent and they
are you know they're not a terribly
warlike people they have been under
assault by the Russians and the Brits
and the Americans and everybody else and
it seems to me that they are the most
powerful country in the Middle East and
they have some right to exert there
they're not not dominate but they have
you know their presence and the one more
thing I had I looked up on there on the
website of the Energy Department is that
they have a great year of natural gas
and why they're developing nuclear
energy at all is a mystery to me and
I'll just leave you open for some
comment perhaps thanks Robert Baer at
Berkeley you that yeah that poses a
couple questions for me and one is you
have to look at first of all from the
Iranian perspective it's got two
American armies on two of its borders
Afghanistan and Iraq in 2003 when we
invaded Iraq we were talking about Iran
being a part of the axis of evil the
implication was that we might attacked
Iran next so we fed Iranian paranoia at
point you know Iran was invaded by
Russia and 46 there was the most--it a
coup in 53 you know the fact is I've
read the Mossadegh files we had a
limited role in the overthrow of the
prime minister in 53 nonetheless the
Iranians tend to be paranoid about this
subject and they're paranoid right now
because we're still talking about
bombing Iran so when you when you see
the Iranians acting irrationally they do
have a reason for it now as for the
nuclear energy what they'd like to do
they have a very large population 70
million there there their oil fields are
are depleted a lot of them are what they
would like to do is use that remaining
oil to sell on international markets and
domestically use nuclear energy now that
doesn't mean to say they're not
developing a nuclear weapon which they
probably will someday but there is a
reason that they want these nuclear
reactors and it's a very good reason now
as far as not opening them up for
inspections what they're saying is what
the Israelis don't open up their nuclear
facilities why should we now we would
have a ready answer for that because we
don't trust you but I mean it's not one
that the Iranians can accept they look
at the certain fairness doctrine on
their side they're saying you know fine
if everybody wants to open up their
facilities we will - it's not going to
happen
but that's the that's the dilemma we
face is we try to go into negotiations
with Iran next call for our guest New
York City B is on the Democrats line hi
there hi there I'd like to ask you mr.
beer do you think that the policy will
be successful and improving
relationships whether look very ran as
long as the press in this country
especially the white male press mostly
from Irish American press is so so
concentrated on because of some kind of
inadequacy I guess that they're feeling
on bringing down Barack Obama are
challenging him than they are in
improving what is greater for America
thanks mr. beer before answering the
question explained in
interview what is the policy right now
the US policy toward Iran how can you
describe it well you know the
intelligence community has on the books
the National Intelligence Estimate it
says that Iran stopped making a bomb in
2003 that has not changed since 2000 the
last six years on the political side
it's there is a belief that Iran is
moving ahead with a bomb and you in be
is absolutely right you see this in the
press they're going to have a bomb in a
year they're going to have a bomb in six
months frankly since I've been in the
CIA since 1980 we've predicted every
four years there's going to be a bomb
and they're never obviously has been one
so I don't know where that stands in
terms of the intelligence community they
haven't made that public yet
I don't think Iran wants a bomb
particularly right now it's it's got
other issues to deal with first
internally it has to worry about Iraq as
well as Afghanistan 20 years maybe but B
is absolutely right that the press in
this country is absolutely and press is
a big word but I see a tendency for
people dealing with the Middle East that
we have to do something about this
regime in Iran about off medina shot the
line now is he's not a legitimate
president of iran
he's an apocalyptic Shia he's going to
attack Israel we have to do something
it's fairly shallow analysis obviously
because it's red it's much more
complicated than that
but Iran is in a sense if I can put this
way the third rail of American politics
you know I could write a book about Peru
anything in the world and people would
completely ignore it but when you write
about Iran it just it sends hackles up
people's back look at the book the devil
we know dealing with the new Iranian
superpower the author is Robert Baer
ex-cia he is out in Berkeley California
this early-morning form Raleigh North
Carolina Lewis here on the independent
line hi this for taking my call just
wanted to say I really don't know why
everyone's so threatened by Iran I feel
like they're a country that heading in
the right
rection I think this is just a bunch of
propaganda to make them seem like an
evil superpower you know I I totally
agree I just will one let's let's let's
let's get right to the issue can we
afford to go to war with Iran and the
answer is no if we think that we're
going to bomb their nuclear facilities
in a tactical strike and that's going to
be the end of it that's completely
misunderstanding the country of Iran it
will respond it will respond against the
oil it will respond in the Persian Gulf
it will respond against our troops in
Iraq the chief of staff Joint Chiefs of
Staff has said very clearly there will
be consequences to an attack on Iran our
military is saying wait hold on let's
not make this a political issue let's
consider the military consequences of an
attack and Joint Chiefs of Staff is
absolutely right what did the Israelis
think about that point that you just
made we had an earlier cholera mentioned
that there are elements there that are
very committed to going to war well
what's your take of the Israeli approach
oh I think the absolutely art but they
have a different experience with Iran I
mean Iran looks at Israel as beyond the
international pale if you like in 2006
they fought a war against Israel which
which psychologically was devastating
for Israel they were unable to move
Hezbollah back from the border they lost
a lot of troops they lost a Corvette was
hit by rockets they didn't even know his
fall ahead they accused Iran and the
Israeli point of view is it is an
existential threat to Israel but the
point is that if we go to war with Iran
we're going to pay the price not Israel
and this is what this president is is
going to face this fall here's a Twitter
message here as well mr. Baer can you
comment on how Bush and Obama attempting
to spend millions or billions they right
to defend Europe from an imaginary Iran
threat connect the last administration
this one and the the approach regarding
Europe and Iran
you know it yes it is a problem but you
it's a based on the premise that the
Iranians are irrational Iran does have
rockets that can hit Europe now one day
presumably they could put a nuclear
weapon on this but what your what the
assumption is that Iran is an irrational
power that doesn't care about its
survival I would argue that it's acted
very rationally over the last few years
in fact I would say this acted more
rationally than we have but that that's
that's part of the debate that it is you
can't convince people of this or people
have already made up their minds in this
case next call Los Angeles James on the
Republican line for Robert Baer good
morning LA you there yep let's try
Boston Boston you there yeah I'm here go
ahead sir yeah shortly after 9/11 Iran
reached out to the United States and
they were going to help the United
States but it was vetoed by Israeli
interests within the United States
administration until until the United
States on till the Congress which is
bought and paid for by the Israeli
lovely is that before these people are
expunged there's not going to be any any
movement forward for peace in that part
of the world and I think that's mighty
obvious Thanks Robert Baer any thoughts
I'd like to address one point is he's
look when we went into Afghanistan in
October 2001 there was a general called
their fame he's still in Afghan politics
he is I wouldn't call him an Iranian
asset but he certainly answers to Tehran
in many ways he's at a chic he speaks
Persian it was his troops that we
marched into Kabul with the special
forces in the CIA and that was thanks to
a green light from Tehran so Iran was
completely on our side when we we got
rid of the Taliban in 2001 but Iran
remained because of Washington politics
as part of the axis of evil this is
again goes back in the Middle East
people it seems to me can't look at this
rationally and just calculate and
in pure power terms is a very emotional
issue Iran because what for Israelis and
in pro-israel lobbies in this country is
that Iran is an existential threat and
that we were not going to have a second
Holocaust and this is a message that
addresses many Americans emotions and
sentiments as well as politics in
Washington you know it's it's a tough
issue to deal with and I feel I do feel
sympathy for this White House it simply
cannot say we're going to give this five
more years and see what happens or we're
going to wait until they test a nuclear
bomb and then we'll deal with it there
is a movement on the hill to impose an
embargo on gasoline other embargoes
which very well could touch off a war
Robert Baer put in perspective the the
recent uprisings in Iran following the
election all that video that we saw the
the people protesting the reports of a
deaths and beatings and the like when
you saw that and as you look back these
weeks later what do you take of it a
couple of things I think it's
interesting that nobody predicted it in
this country and even in Iran they
didn't really predict it this was
spontaneous its frustration with the
economy it's a belief that the supreme
leader Khamenei the Ayatollah who truly
controls the country rather than Othman
Ynez HOD is illegitimate he does not
have the credentials of an Ayatollah
there's chafing among the other mullahs
he's also a dictator in many senses and
what we're seeing as the mullahs are
revolting again we're seeing a revival
of the 79 revolution
you know Iran is is a budding democracy
if you like it's a very odd one for us
this is a good sign and I think it's
going to check this regime and it's
going to check how many it is Iran in a
pre revolutionary state I just don't
know the country that well enough and I
don't think I haven't seen analysts in
this country that do either help us
understand the economy and Iran a little
bit better you mentioned the oil fields
are depleting a bit but how else is the
economy put together and what are the
one of the most severe problems there
right now subsidizing flour gasoline
state industries that draw money of
young population high unemployment high
inflation Iranians can't marry this they
don't have place to live
enormous frustration and with the young
people they hate the regime and they go
between apathy and wanting to do
something about it when they came out in
the streets you know the apathy just
melted away when the elections were
apparently stolen we don't know they
were stolen I presume they were but they
came on the streets spontaneously the
question is where does it go from here
Rafsanjani a very important figure in
Iran has come out in support of the
regime this is a turnaround for him 180
degrees which tells me that Ahmadinejad
the president and how meny have
consolidated power and they're starting
to point people from the Islamic
Revolutionary Guard Corps which you know
we could have the same situation for the
next 10 years next call from Daniel on
the independent line who's in Ishpeming
Michigan good morning hey you got the
name right um but the reason I voted for
Obama was inserting like a symbolic way
his name I was wondering what what what
the effect of the people in our end of
Obama's being prior president now mr.
mayor I think there are people in Iran
are very realistic they're on the
internet they read our newspapers they
can analyze the situation they watch our
actions rather than Obama I think they
had a lot of hope when Obama came in I
think they understand at the same time
there's a gridlock in Washington Obama
inherited a what I consider a mess um
private interests lobbying groups he
can't get his health bill through right
now because of lobbying groups and the
same same with national security
interests so the Iranians understand
this and what they're waiting to do is
to see where negotiations go what we do
in Iraq with the violence there are we
going to leave now where are we going to
stay longer if we stay longer this is
going to aggravate our relations with
Iran same way with Afghanistan
if we fail there and add more troops
it's going to make them more paranoid so
they're they're looking they're waiting
for things to develop they're waiting
and they're looking for a real change
you mentioned Iraq mr. barrel water
what is Iran's a relationship right now
with that country its interest in Iraq
if you can speak to that I think they
would like to see well I mean the Shia
do control the sect is the same sect
that's in Tehran they do control Baghdad
now and you have the Prime Minister is a
Shia he's got uneven relations with
Tehran but what they're pushing Maliki
the prime minister of Iraq to do is for
instance to force out the Iranian
dissidents who have been there living
there for years in which they've done
things called the M ek they've they
raided the camp what they would like to
see in Iraq is stability naturally they
do not want to see a civil war there
because it's on their border the chances
of a civil war spilling into Iran are
pretty good and they know that they
would like to see the Americans leave a
quiet Iraq where they would have a
predominance of influence especially in
the Shia South the right now there's no
indication that they intend to take this
Shia government Baghdad and use it as a
springboard to go after the Arab
countries in the Gulf but the Arab
countries is certainly worried about
that and only time will tell
Fayetteville North Carolina is on the
line now Barry Democrat hi there hi um I
was just wanting to I think I was just
thinking anyways and I was going to say
I was wondering how we compare or how we
did compare safe couple years ago into
how we do compare now and that that's
probably the way that were viewed by
Iran and the way that our media no
matter who's in presidency
it's always controlled by corporations
because what is our Obama and even so
common even I'm able to do anything
right now in the media doing everything
against them but yet how are we viewed
by Iran when when our president is a
thing is it what do you call a
floundering Doug Robert Baer yeah okay
you know it looks that way to me I mean
I can't resist mentioning something
about Blackwater the security company
that was hired by the CIA to do
assassinations I mean it does look like
the Washington is controlled by
corporate interests I mean obviously
it's more complicated than that
but Washington is a mess in South
Congress and so are the lobbying groups
and even if Obama's could sit down and
say all right and say to Hillary Clinton
go to Tehran figure out what we can do I
don't think he would survive it
politically I mean my attitude is
centered Tehran find out what they want
see what we can do if we can't she can
come back we just reassess our policy at
that point but I don't think he can do
that I think these issues are are too
emotional for lobbying groups in
Washington for a vast majority of
Americans and he's pretty much stuck
with the last administration's of
politics our guest spent many years at
CIA is also a author of other books
besides the one we're talking about
today one of them is titled sleeping
with the devil remind us mr. Baer what
that books about it's about Saudi Arabia
and I am forbidden from ever going to
Saudi Arabia again it was it's
corruption in the royal family in Saudi
Arabia and what I talk about in that
book is is it is really a dysfunctional
government they can't last forever I
mean if the price of oil still stays
high it will last them many more years
if oil should fall to a very low level
government will collapse it's that easy
but it was it was an attack on something
look I spent my speak Arabic I spent 21
years in the Middle East I have a lot of
air in fact most of my friends are still
Arab but I have a real problem with the
Saudi royal regime because it is corrupt
it's dishonest and it is not going to
help us in the long term you also wrote
a see no evil which we know is the basis
for the film Syriana george clooney
played your character it tell us more
about the that your reflections on that
work Hollywood it make it make it makes
the Middle East look simple I did you
know I wrote this book and it was before
it was actually published I got a call
from Warner Brothers and so we want to
make it into a movie and I thought that
was a joke and I said yes and it
actually the movie came about very
quickly and I traveled with the director
for two months in the Middle East and we
sat down in a cafe in Paris and he says
you know your book doesn't really good
basis for a movie so what's the story
line here and I told him it's when I got
out of the CIA we were month the old
world would not go away and we were
offered a chance my wife and I to
assassinate somebody which we obviously
said no and came home from the Middle
East and and he said I like that he says
a guidance yeah he gets out with no
retirement you know nothing you know no
real future and it's he's he tempted to
stay in this work and he says no and he
ends up in a bad way a guiding light the
movie was very very complicated when
they first sent me the script I didn't
understand a thing but it apparently
worked it did well and it was it was a
new world for me next call for Robert
Baer who'll be with us for about 25 30
more minutes Tupelo Mississippi
Republican caller named Tim hallo on the
air yes sir
okay Thank You c-span having the guest
non-balanced and everything I was there
with a liberal but did want to ask him
about helmet energized remarks about the
destruction of Israel wiping Israel off
the map and then some of the things that
I'm identidad
has said
parting the denial of the Holy cost I
have just a quick comment and I'll hang
up I think the folks over there speak
Farsi and if you could tell us whether
or not he actually said these things or
did he say those things literally or the
press miss translate or anything like
that in the last question I've got is do
you think the United States exert any
influence indirectly in supporting some
of the anti I my dinner jawed parties in
the last election Thanks mr. mayor
that's that's good question
because he did say that and I should add
that recently the chief of staff for the
Iranian army wrote a letter to the
Hidden Imam this is a man that it's that
that's disappeared supposedly in the
canons of Shia Islam he disappeared in
Iraq but in Iran in the junk car and
well people dropped notes down to him at
the bottom of the well and the chief of
staff recently wrote this man a letter
who disappeared in the ninth century so
you have these these these flourishes of
of end times in Iranian political speech
now whether they're serious or not I
can't tell you but what we have to do is
look at the record with Iran and
especially look at Iraq or Iran could
have caused us major problems in Iraq it
could have unleashed attacks on our
supply line it could have kidnapped
American soldiers and I can go on and on
it didn't it does have it is hard a
sense of survival and I think that's
what really we're seeing in Iran let's
look a change overnight
but again if we go into Iran it's
another pre-emptive war we don't really
know who we're fighting or what we're
fighting for we're basing on a war on
Iran on our assumptions and not
necessarily reality how much does this
country know do you suspect especially
his former CIA the government know about
the the inner workings of Iran how
difficult is the country to penetrate
and learn about in that sense oh it's a
it's virtually impossible to know
I ran I mean look the CIA does well when
it's on the ground in a country just as
the military does in Iraq we know so
much more about Iraq obviously than we
even when we went in in 2003 is that we
need embassies we need academics we need
journals we need open source reporting
we need the New York Times we need all
these things but in order to do that you
have to be in the country otherwise what
you're left with in many cases is exiles
that come out or defectors as we call
them who will tell you a story and the
problem is they all have a bias and they
have a motivation for telling you things
and we're often misled I mean this this
has recurred over history with the
Russian Revolution with Vietnam and so
forth and it's very very difficult this
CIA was surprised by the demonstrations
after the 12 June elections they don't
have people in country it's too
dangerous to send them there a lot of
what we deal with in Iran is guesswork
and to go back and answer one question
we were not behind the 12 June
demonstrations that was entirely
internal spontaneous on the flip side
here is a Twitter message mr. Baer has
there been evidence of infiltration of
Iranian intelligence personnel into US
intelligence operations where there's
been one case of a woman who worked for
the CIA and the FBI she went between
both who was supposedly searching
computers for Hezbollah which we assumed
goes back to Iran there's not much
evidence of it that they really care
when I was in the CIA the Iranian
intelligence people avoided us like the
plague I mean you'd go to a party and
you know who they were and as soon as
you walk toward them David head for the
exit so they weren't really after us
they didn't want it they don't want to
know about us they tend Iranian
intelligence to use through surrogates
so if they have you know sources in this
country they're either completely
clandestine you know sabotage networks
we don't know about may be coming up
from South America or they're just sort
of you know casual contacts
next call for our guest Frederick
Maryland
Ibraheim internet caller hi good morning
you know last week August 19 was the
56th anniversary of the coup in Iran
does remove democratically elected
Mohammad Mossadegh as a prime minister
and it was entirely or mostly the job of
CIA mr. Baer says so you had only minor
role in it but my point is we still
talked about something that happened 56
years ago and most likely we'll be
talking about it 56 years from now
because this is a very significant event
it was the greatest calamity that it
befell Iranian nation and people in Iran
have great resentment about what
happened because at that day their
democracy died and the a miracle to be
blamed
practically entirely even the British of
course were involved involved and of
course they were also Iranian agents and
traitors who collaborated you know in in
mr. bear's book he compares he actually
makes the coup d'etat very you know
insignificant not a big deal and says
that the hostage taken in Iran by the
students during the revolution actually
overcompensated what the damage was done
by by the America to Iran which i think
is a very disproportionate sense you
know in this area so I like to invite
mr. Baird to look at Mohammed Mossadegh
calm and learn about the best of
resentment and anger and disappointment
because Americans at the time really
thought America was full liberty and
freedom and independence of the small
nations so really they feel very
betrayed on it and they're not going to
trust it unless America does something
let's hear from our guest out in
Berkeley Robert Baer I certainly see
that point of view if we if we go back
and look at the record of the Mossad a
coup which has been published in The New
York Times you'll see the British
Petroleum
the British Secret Service the
ambassador the Shah himself in an even
general Schwartzkopf father he was in
New Jersey State Police were part of
this coup so I mean it was we can spread
responsibility but the point is that
symbolically the CIA was behind it now
if you're an Iranian and a foreign
government comes in and changes your
prime minister who was popular at the
time no doubt about it was talking about
nationalizing oil resources in Iran it's
a humiliation it's a humiliation not
easily forgotten
just as in 1979 Iran humiliated the
United States by holding its diplomats
in Tehran the the rescue mission was
another humiliation it was a significant
check to American power it probably
contributed the defeat of Carter in a
large sense so there was two
humiliations here but the Iranians have
reason to be paranoid about foreigners
either Russia or the United States Saudi
Arabia right now you have Sunni
extremist groups on its edge which are
in touch with the American government
and there's one of them's called
joong-dal out of Pakistan which is
setting off car bombs and killing police
officers if you're Tehran in a position
you know now in a time of volatility
political volatility you are going to be
looking to the outside and yes the
United States does need to provide quid
pro quos for future cooperation it
simply cannot put Iran in the corner and
say do what we want or else because on
the streets of Tehran people are still
mistrustful the United States even the
so-called Democrats the green between
revolution Mousavi former prime minister
is not a friend of the United States he
mistrust the United States as well so
there's a lot of bad blood to overcome
and yes the most deku is very important
for rain Ian's and we're going to have
when we go
Taron one day and I hope we do we're
going to have to treat Tehran is equals
and not as as a third-world power more
of your calls in just a moment but
Robert Baer wanted to get your thoughts
on the CIA story that's making news this
weekend in the papers here's the
Philadelphia Inquirer a report coming
out this week internal report at CIA
says that the agency used a gun power
drill to threaten detainees they staged
a mock execution as you know that this
type of story generates a lot of buzz
here in town what's your take on that oh
I think it's outrageous I mean look I
was investigated for attempting to kill
Saddam Hussein I've had the FBI yellow
tape my office
you know I on and on and I know what's
happening internally and I feel bad
about the morale but the question is we
cannot have the CIA above law you can't
you the president is wrong you just sink
it we can't move on
if crimes were committed if people were
killed if people were tortured and it's
just not the Justice Department meant
you know memos that the judge allowed
this to happen it's the people that were
killed
it's the mock executions which against
the law there has to be some accounting
for this otherwise we're going to be
it's going to dribble out for the next
twenty years and it's going to be much
worse now do you do it through a special
prosecutor do you do it through a
bipartisan Commission how do you do it I
don't know but you do need an accounting
for this next call Killington Vermont
Jim Democrat hi there you're on with
Robert Baer yes good morning thank you
I'm I'm reading from a article that
appeared in the Middle East forum in
covering post-election Iran written by
an ally of a knee who's a visiting
research fellow at the American
Enterprise Institute a doctoral
candidate in the civil military
relations in Iran with a focus on the
role of the Revolutionary Guard and he
says in this order and I'm quoting all
of this that he contends that Iran is
not in danger of collapse rather it will
emerge from its present convulsion to
change
nation most likely for the worse he
argued that the election fraud and riots
that Iran has occurred the experiencing
of the result of militarization that
Iran has been undergoing since 1997 when
the Ayatollah expanded the powers of the
Revolutionary Guard in order to prevent
reform and he says that the possibility
that the guard will is highly will will
successfully quash the democratic
movement and Iran will transform into a
military dictatorship and that the
transparency of the fraud and cited by
the from the inside of the democratic
forces to action thus giving the guard
and excuse to seize power and he points
out that the president of Iran and most
of the cabinet and majority of the
Iranian parliament are former Guardsmen
and phony concluded by arguing that the
West should unequivocally treat I ran is
a growing threat in particular he called
on America to take a strong anti
Revolutionary Guard stance and to pursue
a policy of containment it's especially
important that the United States work to
forge an international consensus against
the Iranian regime in order to prevent
the Islamic Republic from playing the
major world powers against each other
your comments please sir but the first
half you couldn't be more right there's
been a military takeover since 12 June
the Revolutionary Guard Corps is in
control of most the important ministries
in Tehran the power ministries as we
call them Ministry of intelligence the
new defense ministers from the guards
vahid II he's got a very bad reputation
he's been accused of blowing up the
Israeli center in Argentina these guys
are very the fact this is this is one of
the thesis of my books is these guys are
very dangerous very competent and they
don't play around there has been a
military takeover in Iran now the
question is when you come to the word
containment do you want to provoke the
Revolutionary Guard into reacting in
Iraq and Afghanistan or the rest of the
Gulf or do you find out what they want
first
I think that they've acted fairly
rational in the sense that they've set
out to do something like in Lebanon with
Hizballah and fighting the Israelis and
got it done they've had the sense to
back off
for instance in Gaza and Egypt most
recently they were supplying rockets
Hamas has stood down for further
confrontation from Israel so they are a
very capable group very intelligent very
violent ruthless but in getting rid of
them we need to get rid of the regime in
Iran and that's the question we have to
ask what the thing we do not want to do
is lie to ourselves in Washington which
Washington is so able to easily to do
and that is hit the nuclear facilities
or hit a couple posture on camps and
think it's finished because it will not
be finished we are going we're talking
about something look very much like
World War 3 in the Gulf Twitter message
regarding the military capabilities
Robert Baer mr.bear they write what are
the capabilities of the Iranian military
forces how large they want to know is
the Army and the Navy what do they
capable of well what they're capable
they can think if they have a large
reserve element they've got the military
but you're looking to Revolutionary
Guards which is about a quarter million
and that's really that sort of the elite
forces they control the rocket forces
they are the ones that have hidden
batteries along the Gulf and they're
very much have a deterrence doctrine and
that is right now let's let's go back to
a conflict with Iran they're saying if
you bomb our nuclear facilities we're
going to take out Saudi Arabia's optic
Russ to new earth major facilities we're
going to take off we're going to drive
the price of oil up to five hundred
dollars a barrel if you like I don't
know what it's going to go to it in the
event of a war but it would be very high
it would be very costly for us the
Revolutionary Guard Corps has a
guerrilla capability all through the
Gulf it's got these little small you
know these small boats which can do
serious damage to our fleet our fleet
has done exercises if you use suicide
bombers with
of carrier group we if we tak Tran we
would have to use a months of
bombardment in advance again I say we
don't we don't know where we would see
the reaction it could be in Central Asia
the Gulf it could be in Europe so what
they're doing is it's a relatively small
force but it's got this asymmetrical
warfare capability which worries our
military and the the influence of Iran
on areas around there we've heard so
much about the situation in a Lebanon
and proxies that you even refer to in
your book can you connect the dots with
all of that well the Iranians I mean
they do it on one level they need
plausible deniability they can say well
his ball is an independent but it is in
a sense but you know if if Hezbollah
attacks Israel it ranks as well it's not
us where you know we'll find we arm them
but we can't really control them and
that's up for debate the same with
supplying weapons to Hamas and and in
things that's doing in Egypt and Jordan
and the rest of it what's very unclear
is how much influence Iran has through
the Chia population in the Arab world
the Twelver Shia especially in Saudi
Arabia you look at the Mac or Bahrain
which is 70% she could the Iranians
could march into Bahrain in a couple
hours and take the country but could
they cause a revolution in Bahrain with
70% Shia that terrifies the Arabs they
could or even Dubai is is largely a Shia
principality how far could they go they
could they disrupt the Gulf yes
absolutely and this is what had the
Arabs terrified and the Arabs are
terrified that we're going to leave Iraq
we're going to leave this a gaping wound
and there's going to be some sort of
domino effect which is going to go
through the Gulf it does scare people in
the Middle East Iran another tweet mr.
Baer about the military what nations
this viewer wants to know what nations
are considered Iranian military allies
what aid would they provide in the case
of a US or Israeli LED strike speak
speak to the military part of it but
further two friends that Iran may have
around the world
well Syria is pretty much hostage to
Iran in the sense that Hezbollah is such
an important element of Syrian policy
and you know remember that Damascus is
the client of Hezbollah Hezbollah is not
the client of Damascus the Syrian regime
is a bit shaky it can't simply say we're
going to cut off aid to Hezbollah we're
going to stop arms from coming to
Hezbollah because then they will be
looked at as pro-israeli so you've got
Syria you've got the Palestinians who
are there's a whole large parts of them
that answer to Tehran in many ways need
their aid need their political backing
you have the Shia in Iraq and you have
the Shia in Afghanistan as well as as
groups in Herat so you're looking at
again on the periphery and then you have
Bahrain as I said 70 percent Shia they
don't have particularly a lot of allies
and that's why they use asymmetrical
warfare the ability to cause problems
the ability to make a war against Iran
too expensive what they would like to do
is is change the I mean but the Iranian
revolutionaries the ones that still
revolutionaries at heart
would like to change the government
Saudi Arabia now the question is do they
have the upper hand or is Tehran more
pragmatic and more looking at its own
survival ten minutes left with our guest
Robert Baer who's in Berkeley California
by the way what else are you doing in
Berkeley these days I write for Time
magazine and I'm writing a book with my
wife we used to work for the CIA
and it's it's a it's a two voices it's
interesting because you talk about each
other it's sort of an experiment with
the publisher bought it let's hear from
Empire Alabama now Sandra independent
caller hi thank you
I enjoyed the talk this morning I have a
couple of questions I'd like to know
what is your opinion on Iran and Iraq
maybe combining in the future and the
land of Babylon that used to be coming
back into existence and along with the
other lands that go where
it and also seems like eschatology says
that's going to happen in the last days
towards the times of Jacob's trouble and
I want to know what you think America's
place will be will they just get further
and further back and just decline and
and not be in the war where they give up
and will Russia and China join in with
Iran Iraq and coming against Israel
thanks mr. mayor there's there's two
interesting aspects to that one is if
you look at it in a fantastical way of
looking at the world is if you had an
alliance I know this sounds a little bit
crazy but it's not impossible between
Iran and Israel bookending the Middle
East would be some sort of ideal balance
of power situation we would serve our
interests now what we're seeing is in
Afghanistan and Iraq is the United
States we cannot stay in those countries
forever we're going to run out of money
we can't afford it in Peyer the Middle
East it's it's it would it would just go
on it would break us bankrupt us the
Chinese gonna stop lending us money
the Americans are already tired of
Afghanistan 51% of Americans I believe
want out sooner rather than later
we're going to have to leave Iraq and
what's going to fill a vacuum is China
and Russia Iran with Russian advanced
weapons or Chinese weapons we have very
formidable power in the Middle East
especially with the retreating United
States you know 65 percent of the
world's proven reserves are in the Gulf
is that somehow should fall under Iran
and Russia's control or China it will
eclipse the United States and there's
very little we can do for Israel at that
point next call Miami Florida John
Republican line you're on with Robert
Baer yes they want a gentlemen
atmosphere thank you for your service to
our country
I really do appreciate that just two
quick two quick things one you know I
was a younger person I was about 10
years old when we experienced his first
Iranian Revolution so I remember there
from a different perspective I'm
wondering that was set up on the basis
and control and power a bunch of young
students and young clergy and religious
people who wanted to change in their
country now the same thing is happening
and the same revolutionaries from before
are kind of pushing this away so I'm
wondering is there some way that these
new revolutionaries might be able to
take power and secondly we mentioned
South America a few times I'm wondering
is there any threat to us that you know
of for South America you know instead of
just Iran in Iraq
it's that's the sliminess at the last
part first and that is you know there
there is indication as we know that
Hezbollah and Iran have operated in
South America let's take the worst-case
scenario could Iran cause problems in
the United States and I'd say yes let's
take a scenario it's probably never
going to happen but the United States
and Iran or in some sort of worsening
confrontation and an Iranian surrogate
setting off a car bomb in New York City
brings down a building somehow they
frame another country it could you know
terrorism is still on us another attack
could you know push this country in a
completely different direction the way
it's going now yes there is a threat
from Iran in in South America now the
Democrats I use that word loosely in
Iran do want to get rid of Khomeini he
is illegitimate he is not truly an
Ayatollah he's an old man he's
increasingly controlled by his son who's
not particularly popular Khomeini 's
supporters from the old days would like
to get rid of him and that's Mousavi
Karroubi as we've seen he ran for the
presidency this time and they are a very
potent force if this regime Tehran
oversteps it's tell itself and goes
against the mullahs and comb and the
more democratic elements there could be
a reaction and they could withdraw
support from Khomeini so if tomorrow
morning there was some another movement
in Iran I wouldn't be surprised now I'd
like to say there's something we could
do to help the Democrats in Iran but I
don't think there is the farther we stay
away from Iran
the less we say about it the less the
more we let them solve their own
problems the better off they're going to
be and we will too robber baron our
remaining few minutes wanted you to wrap
things up as we look toward the epilogue
of the book you do lay out three broad
options you've spoken to them a little
bit but but wrap up your thoughts if you
could you you talk about three broad
options here one of them is possibly
containing Iran one of them is to
provoke a sunni-shia Civil War and the
other is to settle with Iran which is
your preferred option and speak to each
of them if you could I think we should
settle with a rant look there's an
American journalist arrested she broke
the law she was had confidential
documents she didn't have a press ID
she's an American as a severe E and it
was often Dinesh HOD who wrote a letter
to the court and ultimately got her out
I mean off Medina's Schad is as crazy as
he may sound a lot of people does want
to settle with the United States we have
to listen to what he has to say we have
to listen to how many what he says as
well as is the rest of that power circle
around them otherwise we're not going to
know we really have to look at Iranian
actions as opposed to what the country
we would like to see or the country we
believe exists and the way to do that is
to settle with Iran I think that
ultimately Iran would like to be some
sort of hegemon in the Gulf have a
predominance over security affairs but
not necessarily overthrow the regimes in
that country or to go to the war with
the United States they had more
opportunities in the last five six years
than they've ever had and they didn't
they backed off so again we go by their
actions rather than by what they say you
know the sunni-shia conflict is the Mad
Max approach to foreign policy that's
obviously not going to work yes we could
blow up their nuclear facilities but
what we would do is end up possibly
provoking a very large war but what we
would really end up do is strengthening
this regime off medina shot in the
Revolutionary Guard Corps by a pinpoint
strike like this which is the last thing
we
want to do let's hear from Queens New
York bernie is on the Democrats line hi
Bernie
good morning why earlier on you you
refer to a Russian invasion of Iran and
I'm racking my head could you tell us
when this happened and what what were
the circumstances about the invasion
ended the Russian troops came across the
border right after World War two and
they had a they had the red mullahs and
the MER Abad and the Kurds and the rest
of it it was a very small one but it was
that the regime was collapsing at the
time they sort of seeped in and you know
you really are in first nuclear
confrontation with the Soviet Union was
over Iran since 46 the first that's when
the Cold War started was over Iran it's
something the Iranians never forgot just
as they never forgot the most at a coup
and and the fact that you know the the
de queijo dynasty was always subject to
foreign you know trepidations people
coming in for it's going to do this
forcing them to give up Bahrain for
instance and I ran is in a sense a very
modern country yet it's very xenophobic
it's had a very unfortunate history of
being invaded for thousands of years and
and it's in the Iranian soul that's
always there one last call here from
Joan who is in Clyde North Carolina on
the independent line good morning Joan
good morning how I both used one and I
want to thank us c-span please forgive
me I'm a little nervous I would also
like to thank mr. Baer than listening to
you I'm a political writer for about 20
years now in my own right and I agree
probably almost 98% of what you've been
saying I would like to thank the lady
abut that called in about three or four
calls ago talking about Russia and China
are versus the Middle East and just like
to make a quick comment if I may when
Bush invaded elect and was asking for
help for backup
Russia said no she could not do it
because of her investment in Iraq China
also said no she could not do it because
of her investment therefore the lady
that called
if these two countries have investments
in Iraq they definitely are going to
stand side-by-side to go against Israel
at least that's my opinion
appreciate your thoughts Robert Baer
final thought on the future of Iran and
its relationship with this country the
US I think we're going to find out in
October or November you know they've
ordered these bunker busters they've
sped them up the administration has gone
to Tel Aviv and says we will settle this
one way or another come this fall I
think you can see an enormous amount of
pressure Norma's amount of pressure on
this president to do something about
Iran nuclear negotiations it could
probably reopen how far they're going to
go I'm not sure but it could go either
way Robert Baer former CIA operative for
many years author of the book new book
the devil we know dealing with the new
Iranian superpower he's out in Berkeley
California thanks a lot for your time
thanks much was great